noticias de la salud y con más Romero
salas mar Buen día para usted Buenos
días Ángela vamos a hablar de las
últimas declaraciones del departamento
de energía del gobierno de Estados
Unidos concluyó que no es nada
descabellada la teoría del origen de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 que nos habla de una
fuga de laboratorio cuéntenos sí es un
debate cíclico no va apareciendo y
desapareciendo desde que empezó la
pandemia del covid 19 con nuevos datos o
nuevas opiniones Vamos a repasar en este
espacio que sabemos y que no pero antes
de nada explicamos bien Un poco De dónde
salen estas declaraciones no hay varias
agencias de inteligencia de Estados
Unidos en una veintena que trabajan
integradamente pero también por separado
con sus valoraciones de riesgo aparte
una de ellas es el departamento de
energía y que en este caso pues les han
dicho que consideran aplausible Al menos
que el origen de la pandemia de Kobe 19
fuera a raíz de una fuga del laboratorio
del instituto de virología de wuhan el
lugar donde empezó la pandemia tenemos
esa teoría nuestra posición a la teoría
digamos a natural de un origen zoonótico
de la enfermedad que sigue siendo la más
extendida en todos las agencias
gubernamentales de Estados Unidos y
también es importante aquí recalcar que
aunque hablan de esta posible salto no
de a partir de un laboratorio en wuhan
no significa que se parezcan nada nada
que tenga que ver con ningún tipo de
guerra biológica ni nada no significa
que crean que fue un virus diseñado no
significa que crean que fue un virus
intencionadamente puesto en la población
humana simplemente que podría haber
habido esta fuga accidental en el
laboratorio también importante recordar
que lo valora con una confianza baja es
decir a pesar de que sigue siendo para
ellos la explicación más plausible lo
hacen con confianza baja lo confidencen
eso significa que no hay suficiente
información para tener una conclusión
más sólida pues complicado porque
entonces seguimos en las mismas qué
datos hay que puedan apoyar la teoría de
esta fuga de laboratorio pues nos vamos
a remitir a la misión de la OMS en 2021
que fue a visitar a para entender que
había sucedido no las conclusiones
principales es que lo más probable es
que el origen fuera natural sin embargo
también valoraron la hipótesis del
laboratorio de nuevo Qué es lo que ellos
pues con más confianza podían decir que
como ha pasado además anteriormente con
otras enfermedades el virus del covid-19
el sars 2 está en un reservorio de
animales que en este caso serían los
murciélagos saltó a un animal
intermediario que no se conoce todavía
Cuál es Es una de las incógnitas y que
de ahí saltó a los humanos en el mercado
de buhana Sin embargo que tenían por
decir respecto a la hipótesis del
laboratorio que también la valoraron
como decíamos el cristal extracto de su
informe que básicamente lo que dice es
que hay algunos puntos a favor algunos
argumentos a favor así la probabilidad
sea muy baja y es que primero ha pasado
con anterioridad que haya personas que
se originen pequeños brotes a raíz de
fugas de Laboratorios de los virus que
se están estudiando Aunque nunca ha
generado epidemias a nivel global
también también hablan de que el
coronavirus más parecido al Kobe 19 que
se ha encontrado se manejó se secuenció
en el laboratorio de biología de wuhan y
también que en las instalaciones hubo un
traslado no se trasladaron de donde
estaban a un lugar muy cerca del mercado
de Luján ese instituto de virología en
diciembre de 2019 que es cuando empieza
un poco todo entonces Esos son los
argumentos que la misma OMS reconoce que
estarían a favor sin embargo Pues hay
muchos más en contra para empezar que
las cifras las fechas de ese manejo de
ese virus no coinciden exactamente con
lo que debería ser y que no hubo ningún
reporte de incidentes en ese momento del
traslado lo que sí está claro es el
papel del mercado de wuhanne como origen
del brote O al menos parece estar sí
está bastante sustentado por ejemplo en
publicaciones del año pasado de la
revista scies que hicieron una
investigación muy exhaustiva alrededor
de eso y de esos primeros momentos no de
ese noviembre diciembre de 2019 en este
gráfico vemos uno de los mapas que están
en ese estudio publicado el año pasado
vemos los puntos en naranja son los que
se sabe que había un vínculo con el
mercado de wuhan los que están en azul
son los que no se conoce ese vínculo es
decir que las personas estaban
infectadas pero no habían ido
recientemente al mercado sin embargo se
entiende que pues con la forma de
contagiarse que sabemos ahora que tiene
el Kobe 19 es perfectamente plausible y
además se ve como están todos alrededor
del mercado de Juana que es el nombre
que tiene Este mercado de la ciudad
China de wuhan Así que teniendo estos
datos con estas investigaciones es muy
difícil que hubiera empezado alguna otra
forma al menos en lo geográfico en la
localización del inicio y en conclusión
entonces seguimos teniendo incógnitas
alrededor del origen del virus claro y
el problema es que alrededor de estas
incógnitas es donde nacen las teorías no
más Quizás menos sustentadas por decirlo
de alguna forma Aunque eso no significa
que no haya cosas que todavía a día de
hoy te van a esclarecerse por ejemplo
una de las grandes incógnitas es la
genealogía del virus todavía no se tiene
muy clara no cómo se llega al sarsco 2
del más cercano el virus más cercano
tiene nombre de radge 13 se encuentra en
una especie de murciélagos muy extendida
en China y se encontró en la provincia
de yunan que es fronteriza con mi al mar
en 2013 sin embargo este pues este virus
Comparte el 96% de genoma con el sars 2
que puede parecer mucho pero en realidad
a nivel evolutivo es muy poco a falta
todavía mucho para llegar a un virus
como el sars esa es una de las
incógnitas también como decíamos cuál
fue ese animal huésped que hizo la
conexión entre los murciélagos y los
humanos se tienen hipótesis Pero todavía
no se sabe con certeza y es algo pues
que pasa mucho alrededor en temas de
ciencia no hasta que no se demuestre con
hechos concretos que eso no sucedió
todavía con el tema de la Pues de la
teoría del laboratorio nos vamos a tener
que mover en el rango de lo improbable
No esas palabras que no podemos decir
con certeza que no haya sucedido sino
que es poco probable el tema queda
abierto a discusión mar y nos quedamos
también con más preguntas que respuestas
gracias a usted como siempre en esta
sección gracias